there are people who read books by title
only
and uh see fit to criticize them on that
basis and I think the selfish Gene has
suffered a bit from that because people
have thought it was a book about
selfishness they thought it was a
statement that we as a matter of fact
are selfish they've even thought it was
an advocacy of selfishness of course
it's none of those
um
it was suggested to me by uh the by a
publisher
Tom nashler that I should have called it
the immortal Gene The Immortal Gene is
actually a major theme in the book and
he made the point that Immortal is an
upward where a selfish is a downward
and I think he's had a point I I'm not
saying I regret the selfish Gene but if
it had been called The Immortal Gene it
would have been treated in a different
way and somehow it's got a slightly more
Carl saginish feel about it
sort of the a more poetic field do you
think he would have done as well
no
you don't think you should no I think
really provocative titles like that do
well I've had this argument with Michael
Rogers the the uh publisher of the book
and he's adamant that the self-esteem
was the right title I still suspect that
the immortal Gene might have been better
but it was certainly provocative and you
mentioned how people took it and it's
interesting it came out in 1976 three
years before uh Margaret Thatcher came
to power and some people even thought it
was somehow part of the spirit of that
age about no such thing as society and
selfishness that was part of the
misunderstanding that you felt in that
period very much so yes I mean I I know
who you're referring to and I won't
mention his name but yes
I'm not saying that certain Oxford and
Sussex Dons are directly responsible for
the election of Margaret Thatcher but
um so for for people who read the book a
while ago or could benefit from a little
refresher course we turned to sue
Blackmore can you just walk us through
because some of your work has picked up
very much and built on the foundations
of Richard Dawkins
jeans memes and I know you've added this
new term teams who may even get to that
but just walk us through what what these
terms mean and that and how rich are
changed our understanding of them
well I'll go back to the selfish Gene
because what was so powerful about that
is what I took Richard to be trying to
do apart from explaining selfish genre
was to say that genes are not the only
replicators so we elucidated the idea of
the information that's copied with
variation and selection Darwin's
wonderful idea you all you need is three
steps some kind of information it's
copied it's not copied exactly the same
we get some variation and then you
select among the variants if you grasp
that
you can't really believe in God anymore
anyway we get to that later we certainly
could happen but but the point is that
at the end of the book what Richard did
was to say well I'm trying to explain it
as universal Darwinism this principle
you get those three things anywhere at
all and you will have this profusion of
of complexity of Design coming out of of
apparently Simplicity that applies to
all of biology but at the end he tacked
on this this question trying to make
people understand it better I hope I'm
being fair to what you're trying to do
and said are there any other replicators
on this planet Earth and he said yes
just look around all around you I mean I
can look at you a lot look at your
clothes look at your hairstyles got the
glasses you've got under your shoes look
at the seats and the carpets and all of
these things in these terms are
information competing to be copied and
he called that information when he said
I hope my classicist friends will
forgive me if I abbreviate my meme which
means that which is copied to meme which
sounds a bit like Gene and that was how
the term meme was was produced at the
end of the book
now
I didn't even really notice this when I
read the selfish Gene back in 1976 when
I was a PhD student it was years later
20 years later that I reread it and I
realized the power of uh Universal
Darwinism that we can look at the world
in terms of replicators competing
to to uh get copied and in terms of us
the selfish Gene is a brilliant title
it's like people hate it well they hated
the title of my book the meme machine
and the Germans even written the
translation refused to call it the meme
machine because Germans don't like the
idea that we're machines nobody likes
the idea that we're machines but you
know that's the idea that comes out of
this so we are the copying Machinery
that copies the memes in principle
there's no reason why you shouldn't have
further replicators piggybacking on top
of that so out of the gene machines or
the plants animals humans come the Mean
Machines just humans are doing copying
imitation and so on and I'm
playing with the idea that now we have
produced uh computers and that copy
information with High Fidelity maybe
there's a new replicator emerging I've
called it I call it teams and people
spelled it wrong and thought it was
football so I've subsequently called it
dreams choose which is better it's a
meme fight one or the other will win but
but it's just taking Universal Darwinism
as what I think Richard intended look
for replicators see how they compete and
see how all this stuff appears because
of that process of natural selection and
the process of replication exists in the
biological orbitals in the cultural
world yeah but before you hear from the
man himself let's bring in Daniel
Dennett
um on by video and uh
Professor Dennis
you have written about Darwin's
dangerous idea and also said that
actually of all the human ideas in a way
Darwin's is the very best uh that any
human being almost ever had can you just
tell us more about that why this idea
partly explained to The Wider world
through Richard dawkins's book but why
this idea is so powerful
sure I think
the the key idea is that if you look
around and think what is there
there's meaning there's poetry there's
art there's there's philosophy there's
culture and then there's matter there's
physics and chemistry and so forth and
how do we put those two worlds together
and until Darwin came along people kept
them really apart the world of meaning
the world of the humanities was one
thing the world of the mind and then
there was the world of matter and and
and they they didn't have any uh you
couldn't get from one or the other and
then Darwin comes along with this master
stroke this strange inversion of
reasoning where he says no unpacked
minds and everything that we think of as
mind made
can be can emerge from natural selection
and create the whole world of not just
of life but of human culture and art
everything that exists in the human
world ultimately
are fruits on the tree of life
it's not just genes as Sue says there's
also cultural replication which is a
very big part of it
let me just
just comes to my mind hearing Daniel
Dennett to you Richard Dawkins
the idea that this was this
extraordinary idea of this one person
Darwin a moment of inspiration or genius
you would think that this thing that is
just about us science or even though you
know through darwini Theory we would
have got there anyway how come it takes
one random individual a moment of kind
of almost and I'm doing this
deliberately to wind you up Divine spark
of Genius
um surely just through the sort of
natural process we'd have got there
anyway it baffles me why it took till
the 19th century because I would have
thought I mean I agree with Dan that
it's uh the it's the best idea anyone
ever had in the sense that it's the most
revolutionary what it explains divided
by what you need to postulate in order
to explain it is is huge I mean the the
ratio is gigantic and you think that
Aristotle would have got it you think
that that you know Pythagoras would have
got it to Hume would have got it
um why did it wait for one actually two
19th century naturalists
um to get this
stunningly powerful yet stunningly
simple idea
um and I don't think that question's
really been satisfactorily answered it
could be that the idea is so powerful
that it seemed obvious to people that it
couldn't have an answer that the the
beauty the Elegance of a natural world
couldn't possibly be explained in terms
of simple mechanics and therefore it had
to be done by a supernatural designer
and it required therefore an immensely
bold stroke to to depart from that and
to say that there is a natural
explanation and Darwin and Wallace did
it um in the 19th century can I do you
want to come in on this one
um I think it could have been
um
derived from reason alone but it wasn't
derived from observation exactly
um and surely it was derived at that
point because uh scientific observation
very precise detail scientific
observation had become a discipline
which is which has developed and evolved
to the point where you could notice very
very small differences between things I
think that's entirely right and that's
why it was Darwin and Wallace who got it
they were both expert
highly experienced field naturalists
nevertheless if you're looking for a
great idea which could have been had in
from the depths of an armchair yes it is
it is it I mean anybody in an armchair
could could have could have thought of
it they didn't it had to wait for field
naturalists
we don't know that they didn't I'm
wondering how many great minds there
were who sort of thought about it but
it's it could it be people hate it so
much we've talked about how much they
hate the phrase of selfish Gene and Mean
Machines and so on it's taking humans
down from their pedestal we start and we
know this from psychology developmental
psychology of children we kind of start
as dualists we start as designers we are
the powerful ones we're in charge we
design stuff to make that flip that
Darwin made and that you then extended
in the selfish Gene
um is is very hard and emotionally
people don't want to do it I'm not
saying that Aristotle did think of it
and didn't dare take it any further but
it's quite possible that it was that
emotional antagonism that meant it took
so long and after all
wrongly said you know he suddenly had
the idea I mean Darwin worked on that
for 20 odd years before he
did come out with it because it's so a
offensive to people yeah I mean Stephen
Pinker if you're able to hear us I'm
interested where you stand all this I
mean because people debate always the
sort of great man theory of History the
idea of if that one individual had not
come along would this big thing have
happened big historical events where in
science do the sort of Talent OR Genius
of individuals you know present company
included but where where does that fit
in in how we make these great leaps
forward and we've talked a bit about how
it came to Darwin and others
uh it's uh I don't think it was so
obvious that uh that it was inevitable
it was that someone would have come up
with it nor that we should be surprised
that no one had got thought of it
beforehand Susan mentioned that there is
something uh in human intuition that
works against understanding Evolution
namely that when we see complexity when
we see design we assume that there's a
designer and it's actually quite a
conceptual leap to say that complexity
comes from reproduction through
replication when I took high school
biology the reproductive system was just
like you know the liver the pancreas or
the muscles it's just a system of the
body Darwin's idea was that if it
weren't for reproduction life wouldn't
exist there were ideas such as
spontaneous generation that mice could
spontaneously generate from piles of
straw uh we now know thanks to Darwin
that that just could not have happened
even logically as without reproduction
that could not be adaptive complexity
it's not to two
to explain one set of phenomena the
astonishing richness of life with
another the ability to replicate is an
enormous conceptually it doesn't
surprise me at all but it took thousands
of years
but of course because it is a we now
know it's the correct idea because of
the coincidence that two people came up
with nor that some uh would have come up
eventually but it does not occur
naturally to us
Darren you're like me you're not a
scientist with the sort of lay people on
this panel a bit did the ideas in
Richard dawkins's work even to the
non-scientists do they speak to you
somehow
yes yes of course
um and obviously I was just thinking
that the the
Richard I think himself has said that
the the god idea is the opposite idea of
of evolution in that it what it needs so
much as an explanation is way out of
proportion to what it actually explains
it does the very opposite of of
evolution
um so Stevens just said that idea of
people getting their head round that
something's so complicated could be
explained by something so simple
given the sort of earlier
culture and the life that people had
which was so theologically focused that
the idea of
the very eye that it's such a reversal
of what was taken for granted that it is
a huge is a huge conceptual lead for
anybody to make it massive and one of
the things that I was talking about how
people seized on the idea and in some
ways misunderstood it and you might even
think willfully did one thing that
happened that maybe we'll bring in
Stephen Pinker on this is the idea that
somehow you know genes were Destiny and
this is what Drew decided people even
individually it was all encoded that's
been an area a sort of misconception in
you know popular thinking for decades do
you
role did your book play in either
confounding that or actually because of
that potential to misunderstand in
people thinking ah so that person's like
that yeah insofar as it played a role it
was it was massively misunderstood I
mean um the question of Destiny is a
deep philosophical question which down
then it's contributed a lot to but it
doesn't become a different problem if
you suddenly bring genes in so we can
ignore the idea of genetic determinism
because I had one more thing to the
mystery of why it took so long
um Ernst Meyer the great centenarian
founding father of modern evolutionary
genetics
um suggested that it was because of
platonic essentialism
um if you if you if you're a geometer
like like Plato then then you'll see a
triangle
um as a or something or a sphere as an
ideal form
and he regarded real triangles and real
spheres as kind of imperfect
approximations to this ideal Meyer's
theory is that people were used to that
idea applied to living things he had an
ideal rabbit an ideal rhinoceros and
real rabbits and real rhinoceroses were
approximations to this ideal form and if
you think of if you think of rabbits and
rhinoceroses and kangaroos as having
ideal forms you're automatically
resistant to the eye that they could
change into something else
so that's Maya's explanation for why it
took so long there so there was actually
a barrier in the way the Dead Hand of
Plato yes